was
[Silence]
gentlemen.
Gentlemen,
you
alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
in the book of fasting.
This chapter is regarding upon whom
fasting is obligated.
So what are the points of criteria that
a person must meet in order for fasting
to be obligated upon them? Notice the
wording here. The wording the wording
here is obligated.
It doesn't mean that this criteria is
for fasting to be accepted or fasting to
be valid. A person's fasting may be
valid
even if they don't meet a couple of
the points here of this criteria.
However, this is regarding upon whom
fasting is obligated.
You are obligated to fast if you meet
these points of criteria.
say
in his book.
Muslim.
Say
mentions in his book
that the scholars have all come to a
consensus. All of the fuka of Islam have
come to the consensus that fasting is an
obligation
upon those who meet five points of
criteria.
that a person is Muslim, a person is
sane, a person is of the age of puberty,
that a person is healthy enough to fast,
and that a person is a resident, meaning
the opposite of a traveler.
And an additional point of criteria for
females is that a woman not be in a
state of ministration or postpartum
bleeding. Now, we'll explain each of
these points, but it's important that we
keep in mind five points
for the obligation of fasting. Fasting
is obligated upon the Muslim who is sane
above the age of puberty
healthy and a resident as opposed to a
traveler meaning not traveling
and for a female that she is not in a
state of menration or postpartum
bleeding. Now ministration and
postpartum this is not an illness okay
but it has the ruling
of the for a person to break his fast
due to illness. It is not an illness
obviously. Actually, if it doesn't
happen, something is usually wrong. But
it is something that runs in the vein of
the ruling for the person who is ill,
someone who is not fasting due to
illness. We'll discuss all of that.
Likewise, , old age, very old to where
fasting is possible, but very hard. It's
tolerable. They could push through it.
They could soldier through it, but it's
very difficult. It's difficult to the
point that it is perhaps very
uncomfortable.
This here is not in itself illness. Old
age is not illness. However, it runs in
the same vein as illness and we will
discuss the types of illness and their
rulings inshall.
The first point is that a person is
Muslim. What does that mean? The
scholars often
mention this point of criteria for a lot
of the obligations of Islam. That
salah is obligated upon a Muslim.
That zaka is obligated upon a Muslim.
that fasting is obligated upon a Muslim
and this is often misunderstood
by many people when the fa say that
Islam is a condition
it doesn't mean that only the Muslims
are being commanded by Allah to fast
that is not correct
it doesn't mean that the Quran
is only for the Muslims. That Muhammad
Sam
was only sent to the Muslim. That if a
person disbelieves or if a person is not
a Muslim that they will not be held
accountable on the day of resurrection
for failing to uphold the laws and
requirements of Islam. That's not what
is meant. the command of fasting is
for everyone Muslim and non-Muslim.
However, when we say Islam is a one of
the five points of criteria for fasting
to be obligated upon them. Meaning a
person who is not Muslim is not begin
with fasting. If they were to fast,
their fasting would not be valid. It
would be invalid.
Fasting is obligated upon the Muslim.
It's obligated upon those who are not
Muslim. However, those who are not
Muslim are not told you need to fast. At
least fast. No, they are told to enter
into Islam. They are told to begin with
the testimony
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillasool.
before this if a person were to fast
of course their fasting would be
invalid.
And so this point here is important for
us to distinguish. Sometimes people have
in their mind that Muslim when you enter
into Islam, you've got all these rules
and all these responsibilities and
you're held to account for failing to
comply. But if a person were just not
Muslim that there's no judgment upon
them. No. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us
in
that the people of the hellfire are
asked.
They said when they are asked what has
landed you in this hell in this
damnation
their response is what we didn't pray we
were not of those who prayed so the
scholars take from this verse and others
it that
a person who rejects Islam
does not become Muslim they will be held
to account for rejection of Islam but
they will also be held to account for
all of the rulings of Islam that they
failed to comply with. They say, "Well,
I didn't know. You didn't know because
you rejected the whole religion." And so
the person will still be held to account
for that.
The second point of criteria is
is sanity.
And oftent times sanity is conflated
with emotional instability.
So insanity and emotion instability,
emotional instability, they are two
different things. Modern psychiatry or
modern psychology might kind of view
those as all being in the same pool in
the same vein, but they are not. A
person could
have disorder, some kind of disorder. Or
they could have some you know
clinical depression or generalized
anxiety disorder or a person could
have
of
what are referred to in a very general
sense as mental illnesses. But this
doesn't really have much to do with
sanity as understood by the fa of Islam.
The jurists of Islam
they say they tell us that sanity and
insanity
they are distinguished by
one very clear common thing and that
is a person who is considered to be
Islamically sane is someone who can hold
a coherent intention
is someone who can hold a coherent
intention.
If a person is able
and is of sound mind enough to be able
to hold a coherent intention,
if you imagine with me someone who is
insane, they come in and see everybody
making wool and so they start splashing
around in the water with everybody,
right? They see someone put their foot
up, they put their foot up. They see
someone wash their arm, they wash their
arm. If you ask them, "What are you
doing?"
You know, they they don't know what
they're doing. They're not coherent
at that point. However, a person who is
considered to be Islamically sane is
someone who is able to have a coherent
intention that is clear. I am doing this
for this reason. My intention is to
fast. Fasting is 1 2 3 etc. They
understand the difference between
fasting and not fasting. They understand
the difference between so this is
considered to be sanity and this is the
distinguishing factor between the
sane and the insane. Number three is
alik.
Albik
is someone who is of the age of puberty.
Now we need to discuss what puberty is.
Puberty is a physical reaction or a
physical change that takes place in the
body once the brain and the body is
mature enough to be considered able to
distinguish right from wrong.
This is called this is called puberty
right and this is legislative adulthood.
Sometimes, a lot of times in our modern
society,
, adulthood and maturity
are,
, conflated, confused,
just what are referred to as mental
illnesses and sanity are confused or
insanity. Likewise,
confusion takes place between adulthood
and maturity.
Person could be 35 and still be very
immature. Have the maturity of a
12year-old. That is not just possible.
It's becoming more and more probable.
Right? Maturity is not the issue here.
The issue is that a person is of
pubescent age to where they are
able to understand the difference
between right and wrong and able to tie
consequences to actions.
This is now an age of puberty and the
body reacts to this. The body reaches a
sexual maturity
and the body reaches a mental maturity.
Enough for this. So puberty has been
discussed at length by the scholars of
Islam. What is the true criteria for
puberty?
We can simplify it and say a person
reaches the age of puberty when one of
three things happens. For girls it is
four things. For boys it is three
things. One of these three things
happens. First this person has reached
the age of puberty. Number one
is that a person starts to grow pubic
hair around their genitals. This is one
indicator of pubescent age. Number two,
the person has or the the child reaches
maturity and this is
this is is articulated
when a child is able to have what is
called
is the ability to sexually
be gratified sexually that a child
may have what is called a wet dream.
This is another point. If none of these
two things happen, if neither of these
two things happen, 15 is the latest.
At 15 years old, everyone is an adult.
Now, remember, we're using that word
adult in Islamic law,
meaning that this person now is being
judged for their actions. doesn't
necessarily mean that they should be
trusted with a vehicle at 15. It doesn't
necessarily mean they should be trusted
with a firearm at this age. Doesn't
necessarily mean that they should be
trusted to pilot a Boeing 737. That's
not what is meant here by adulthood.
Adulthood in an Islamic sense, in
Islamic law, is that this child
understands two things. The distinction
between right and wrong and the tiein
between consequences and actions. Even
if these two things are very distant
apart, when they understand these two
things, the latest they would understand
these two things is the age of 15.
And for girls there is one more point
and that is menration.
So if any of these four things happen
for boys three things then this person
has reached the age of puberty. This
person now if they fail to pray they are
held accountable. They are obligated to
fast. They're obligated to pray. They're
obligated to give zaka
etc. Now, of course, the softer our
society becomes and the more comfortable
we are, the more spoiled we become
and the
more immature we become as a people in
general.
It's very common to meet someone that is
45, 50 years old with the emotional
and mental maturity of a 15year-old.
This is very common can still find this
because of the very refined living that
we are exposed to now. We don't have
a kind of lifestyle where mistakes are
very permanent and mistakes are very
brutal.
We have a society in a way set up is the
society of second chances. You always
get a second chance. Even if it's the
50th chance, it's still your second
chance, right? And so nothing is really
really no one is really held
accountable, right? Especially if you
have money, especially if you have
connection, you're not really going to
help be held accountable to the point
that
u even
amenities running water and indoor
plumbing and you know gas in the
house and electricity and so forth. This
has all contributed to a very
comfortable living situation.
And when children are coddled and they
continue to be coddled and coddled until
they're 15, 20, 25, and it's still, oh,
my little baby and my little Swedoms and
my little What happens is immaturity
takes root and then you have a very
immature generation
raising another generation and they pass
that im immaturity down and so forth. it
becomes worse and worse until things,
you know, usually fall apart. Then we
have a great reset, right? And then
things are real difficult again until
they get soft again and so forth. And
for this reason, the companions would go
out of their way to expose their
children to difficulty. They would go
children to difficulty, even
difficulties such as walking barefoot,
difficulties such as difficulties in
amenities and
slightly uncomfortable living
situations. in order to especially for
boys in continue to have that that
roughness and which which breeds
maturity. And so maturity and
and puberty are not the same thing. They
can be different and they very much are
[Arabic recitation]